biggest tasks for nevada state police
and every other local police agency
pedestrian safety in the last four weeks
there have been 10 critical or deadly
crashes involving pedestrians throughout
the year law enforcement target
crosswalks to try and get drivers to pay
better attention today bianca holman
learned why the turkey crossed the road
here at decatur and palmyra it's a busy
intersection and some people may not
know it's also a school crossing zone
people in this west valley neighborhood
walk out of necessity leaving from
apartment complexes to rtc stops and
shopping centers nearby or students
getting on and off the bus
during school hours the speed limit goes
from 45 to 25 but even with these police
officers dressed up like turkeys and
flashing lights some drivers ignore the
signs because you don't see a spool
a lot of people don't slow down so makes
it particularly dangerous for children
getting to school at the beginning of
the month a woman was hit and killed by
a school bus just around the corner near
desert inn and decatur
aaron breen with road equity alliance
project says this could be one of the
deadliest year to date for pedestrian
and vehicle crashes it's just a matter
of not paying a thousand percent
attention and it's a good lesson in why
no distractions pay attention to what
you're doing
lives are on the line with thanksgiving
on thursday breen wants everyone to
figure out their travel plans if you
drink alcohol think about who you want
to stay at your table and act
responsibly so you're sure that they're
there which means also reminding your
friend
law enforcement officials and advocates
tell us there will be more initiatives
like this one throughout the holiday
season b oklahoman live local now